cell division is a complicated and
fascinating process if we see the time
course 90% of the time is devoted to
interphase which is a preparatory phase
whereas 10% of time is devoted to the
division phase or the mitotic phase
which includes prophase metaphase
anaphase telophase all together among
these mitotic phase prophase is the
longest and we would look at the events
that are taking place in the prophase
and how they're regulated so in this
video we would discuss about that in
details now at the end of g2 phase
several changes takes place in the cell
g2 phase is the last time for
preparation it's like a last minute
preparation in that particular point of
time the interphase cell transcribe and
translate whatever enzyme and proteins
it requires during the division process
so it would create all the necessary
proteins and enzymes now at the
beginning of the mitotic phase comes
prophase in the profiles out of many
significant changes chromosomal T
constant column ozone condensation take
place so chromatin chromosomes becomes
more condensed and packaged at this
point of time chromosomes can also be
the pair pair of chromatids can be
visualized using a light microscope now
you can see in the nucleus at the end of
g2 the chromosomal organization is
pretty much relaxed and it is not
entangled at this moment yet but at late
prophase stage you can see that
chromosomes are really started
entangling
and they are forming a higher order
structure more package structure that
makes a lot of sense
let's say you want to move from one
place to another place while you're
moving one place to another place you
need all your substances your valuable
substances
we packed such that you don't misplace
something during this transition right
for sale division is that kind of
transition process in that particular
point sell them to ensure that
chromosome segregates properly and that
is why the package the chromosome super
nicely and then they transfer it into
two daughter cells now this is a quick
overview of the chromosomal architecture
at several phases of this prophase
by the end of the prophase the
chromosome it's super condensed and
totally packaged you're ready to be
segregated into two daughter cells
now several molecular events happen at
the end of t2 and the beginning of the
mitosis one of the most important thing
is the activity of the cycling B and
cdk1 complex which is also known as
maturation promoting factor this is a
potent kinase which can phosphorylate
nuclear pore subunits and which lead to
dissociation of the nuclear pore
subunits not only that our nucleus is
supported by a filamentous structure
it's like a meshwork of filaments known
as lemons lemons are basically
intermediate filaments which has in
terminal of a helix and several IC falls
in the c terminus and there are three
types of lemmings found in a nucleus
which is supporting the nuclear envelope
now this MPF or cyclin b c d 1 complex
phosphorylates lambing in specific
residue as a result the affinity towards
lemon subunits are loosening up
that means lambing separates from each
other the whole laminate structure
collapses and as a result the nuclear
membrane collapse as well but notice at
this point the chromosomes are super
condensed because we are moving towards
the end of the mid prophase and
metaphase would begin soon so the
chromosomes are super condensed and
ready for
segregated into two daughter cells now
another important cellular event is the
migration of the centrioles at the two
opposite poles of the cells at this
particular particular time the
centrioles have asters coming out which
are basically microtubules coming out
from their ends so these are known as
astral Ray's now at the end of the
prophase and at the very beginning of
the metaphase at this point of
transition the astral Ray's or the
microtubules which are coming out of the
centriole or central apparatus you can
see that the microtubules has contacted
the kind of course of the chromosomes
and they are trying to align the
chromosomes into a metaphase plate and
after that metaphase takes place and the
chromosomes are properly placed in the
metaphase plate and separated in
anaphase so I hope this video about
mitotic profit was informative you liked
this video give it a click thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you do let me know in the comments
that how do you like my videos and if
you have any suggestion I would be open
to that